[Musique]
allez viens on y va
si jamais ce mec pose j'explose celui-là
c'est quoi ton problème
on a un pick-up
il y a deux morts
c'était quoi ce bordel on a l'argent
l'argent on a tué deux personnes très
deux hommes qui entrait sortent tu en
penses quoi il va s'agir de pilules
d'argent et d'insultes
fais comme si tu comprenais ce qui est
en jeu c'est mes nièces je comprends ce
qui est en jeu date du nouveau c'est un
d'Empire body ils ont dit que
c'est la mafia
c'est tout rien qui ne puisse être géré
rapidement
je vais récupérer ce qui a été volé
bonjour Shelby
[Musique]
écoute on peut s'arranger c'est pour ça
que je suis ici
on surveille ta famille elles ont rien à
voir avec ça maintenant c'est
[Musique]
cher
je crois pas qu'on se connaisse
est-ce que tu vas bien
tu veux me dire quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est pas ton monde
[Applaudissements]
rien de tout ça
[Musique]
j'ai rien demandé de tout ça
au contraire
[Musique]
on peut tous nous arriver de glisser
vers le bord d'un pont
mais c'est à nous de voir comment on
gère cette situation
[Applaudissements]